hello and welcome to a new edition
of las vegas now in spanish health to
natalia badly had we start talking
about the series of concerts on the beach of
manuela and bella tele mentioned before and
now this august 28 the group
caifanes will take the stage and the
september 18th the group bronco will sing to us
how i'm going to forget you in the light of the
stars to buy your tickets and the
complete list of artists visit
mandalay bay dotcom well now if
you'll be in las vegas' this weekend
i remind you of the unique event  what will happen
in the future some of the
most iconic boy band members
will be presenting the after
party i'm talking about mclean and coria
from the backstreet boys along with dancing
in one amores voicemail i sat
exclusively with her best in that she
told me a little  more about this project
this project
decision injury stretcher my friends
efe
transgression now in isleworth and i
also think it's a very good idea
mu  and good concert by the way the first
night of the after party is this thursday
august 19th and will last until august 22nd
tickets for this show are still on
sale at ticketmaster.com
putting one after party to another
completely different by the
musical life festival  is beautiful
who are meeting
blogging brooklyn bone rather in
berlin for a series of concerts
starting september 15 before the
festival itself beware these concerts
will happen late at night for these
these people are night owls with the
last shows starting  at one in the
morning culminating with the presentation
of the rapper workers on Sunday
September 19 tickets for these
concerts go on sale this
Friday morning
and it is almost time to toast with the feef
team and they are creating a bar of
literal elevated experience
it is about rise and experience a
more like seven minute experience
where you will be lifted 131 feet in the
air where  you will be able to admire the south of las
vegas complete with your favorite drinks
ryser and the only one of its kind in the whole
country and will open its doors to the public
this fall
well here is your decision
las vegas nao in spanish don't forget
you can visit in  snow dotcom in
case you need more information about these
events thank you very much for your
attention see you next week greets you
nathalia barcenilla
[Music]